Buenos días a todos. Siento que -- antes que nada, ha sido fantástico
estar aquí durante estos días.
En segundo lugar, siento que es un gran honor
cerrar esta extraordinaria reunión --
estas increíbles charlas que hemos tenido.
Siento que me he identificado, de muchas formas,
con algunas de las cosas que he escuchado.
Empecé -- vine directamente aquí
desde la muy profunda selva tropical en Ecuador,
donde estaba -- sólo se puede llegar ahí por avión--
con indígenas que se pintan las caras
y usan plumas de papagayo en sus tocados.
Donde estas personas están luchando para mantener alejadas de sus bosques
a las compañías petroleras y a las carreteras.
Luchan para desarrollar su propia forma de vida dentro de la selva
en un mundo que está limpio, un mundo sin contaminar,
un mundo sin ensuciar.
Y lo que me sorprendió, y que tiene que ver exactamente
con lo que hemos estado hablando aquí en TED,
es que ahí, en lo profundo de esta selva,
hay paneles solares -- los primeros en esa parte de Ecuador --
y es, principalmente, para bombear agua
para que las mujeres no tengan que ir por ella.
El agua se limpió, pero como tienen muchas baterías,
pueden almacenar muchísima electricidad.
De modo que cada casa -- y había, creo, ocho casas
en esta pequeña comunidad -- pudiera tener luz
creo que durante media hora cada tarde.
Y ahí está el jefe, en su majestuosa elegancia, con una laptop.
(Risas)
Y este hombre, ha salido de la selva, pero regresó,
y él decía, "Saben, hemos entrado repentinamente
en una era completamente nueva, y hace 50 años ni siquiera conocíamos
al hombre blanco, y ahora aquí estamos con computadoras portátiles,
y hay algunas cosas que queremos aprender del mundo moderno.
Queremos saber sobre salud pública.
Queremos saber lo que hacen otras personas -- estamos muy interesados en ello.
Y queremos aprender otros idiomas.
Queremos aprender inglés, francés y quizá chino,
somos buenos para los idiomas."
Así que ahí está con su pequeña portátil,
pero peleando contra el poder de la presión --
por la deuda, la deuda externa de Ecuador --
luchando contra la presión del Banco Mundial, el FMI y desde luego,
las personas que quieren explotar la selva y llevarse el petróleo.
Y así, viniendo directamente desde ahí.
Pero, desde luego, mi verdadero campo de estudio
está en un tipo muy distinto de civilización --
no puedo llamarlo una civilización realmente.
Un estilo de vida diferente, un ser diferente.
Antes hubo una charla -- esta maravillosa charla de Wade Davis
sobre las diferentes culturas humanas en el mundo --
pero el mundo no está compuesto únicamente por seres humanos,
también hay otros animales.
Y propongo traer a esta conferencia de TED,
como siempre lo hago en todo el mundo, la voz del reino animal.
Frecuentemente sólo vemos unas pocas diapositivas, o parte de una película,
pero estos seres tienen voces que significan algo.
Entonces, quiero saludarles,
como si lo hiciera un chimpancé en los bosques de Tanzania --
¡Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh!
(Aplausos)
He estudiado a los chimpancés en Tanzania desde 1960.
Durante este tiempo, ha habido tecnologías modernas
que realmente han transformado el modo
en que los biólogos de campo hacen su trabajo.
Por ejemplo, por primera vez, hace algunos años,
con sólo recoger pequeñas muestras fecales
pudimos hacerlas analizar -- para hacer pruebas de ADN --
y por primera vez, pudimos saber realmente cuál chimpancé macho
era el padre de cada cría individual.
Porque los chimpancés tienen una sociedad muy promiscua.
Entonces esto abre todo un nuevo camino de investigación.
Y usamos el GSI -- Geographic lo que sea, GSI --
para determinar el rango de distribución de los chimpancés.
Y estamos usando -- pueden ver que no sé mucho de estas cosas --
estamos usando imágenes satelitales
para ver la deforestación en el área.
Y desde luego, ha habido desarrollos en infrarrojos,
de forma que puedes ver a los animales en la noche,
y los equipos de video-grabación
se vuelven cada vez mejores y más ligeros.
Así que de muchas, muchas formas, podemos hacer cosas ahora
que no podíamos hacer cuando empecé en 1960
Especialmente cuando los chimpancés, y otros animales
con cerebros grandes, se estudian en cautiverio,
la tecnología moderna nos ayuda a investigar
los niveles superiores de cognición en algunos de estos animales no-humanos.
De manera que ahora sabemos que son capaces de hacer
cosas que la ciencia habría considerado
absolutamente imposibles cuando yo comencé.
Creo que el chimpancé en cautiverio más hábil
en funciones intelectuales es uno llamado Ai en Japón --
su nombre significa amor --
y ella trabaja con una compañera maravillosamente sensible.
Ama su computadora --
deja su gran grupo, su agua corriente,
sus árboles y todo,
para venir a sentarse ante esta computadora --
es como un videojuego para un niño, se engancha.
Tiene 28, por cierto, y hace cosas con la pantalla de su computadora
y un touch pad que puede usar más rápido que la mayoría de los humanos.
Hace tareas muy complejas, y no he tenido tiempo de meterme en ellas,
pero lo maravilloso acerca de esta hembra
es que no le gusta cometer errores.
Si tiene una mala racha, y su marcador no es bueno,
se acerca y da golpecitos en el cristal --
porque no puede ver al experimentador --
queriendo pedir otra oportunidad.
Y su concentración -- ya se ha concentrado mucho
como por 20 minutos, y ahora quiere empezar de nuevo,
sólo por la satisfacción de hacerlo mejor.
Y la comida no es importante -- obtiene una minúscula recompensa,
como una pasa, por su respuesta correcta --
pero lo haría gratis, si le dices de antemano.
Así que ahí tienen, un chimpancé usando una computadora.
Chimpancés, gorilas y orangutanes también aprenden la lengua de señas humana.
pero el punto es que cuando estuve por primera vez en Gombe, en 1960 --
lo recuerdo bien, tan detalladamente, como si fuera ayer --
la primera vez, cuando estaba atravesando la vegetación,
los chimpancés todavía escapaban de mí, la mayor parte del tiempo,
aunque algunos estaban un poco aclimatados --
y vi esta figura oscura, encorvada sobre un nido de termitas,
y lo miré con mis binoculares.
Era, afortunadamente, un macho adulto al que llamé David Greybeard --
y por cierto, la ciencia entonces me decía que no debía dar nombre a los chimpancés,
que todos debían tener números, eso era más científico.
Como sea, David Greybeard -- vi que él
estaba arrancando pequeños trozos de pasto y los usaba
para pescar termitas de su nido subterráneo.
Y no sólo eso -- a veces cortaba una ramilla con hojas
y le quitaba las hojas.
Modificando un objeto para hacerlo adecuado para cumplir un propósito específico--
el inicio de la creación de herramientas.
La razón por la que esto era tan emocionante y un gran avance
es que en ese tiempo, se pensaba que los humanos,
y sólo los humanos, usaban y creaban herramientas.
Cuando estaba en la escuela, nos definíamos como 'hombre, el fabricante-de-herramientas'.
Entonces cuando Louis Leakey, mi mentor, escuchó esta noticia,
dijo, "Ah, ahora debemos redefinir 'hombre', redefinir 'herramienta',
o aceptar a los chimpancés como humanos."
(Risas)
Ahora sabemos que tan sólo en Gombe, hay nueve formas distintas
en las que los chimpancés usan distintos objetos para diferentes propósitos.
además, sabemos que en distintas partes de África,
dondequiera que se ha estudiado a los chimpancés,
hay conductas de uso de herramientas completamente distintas.
Y como estos patrones parecen pasarse
de una generación a la siguiente, a través de la observación,
imitación y práctica -- eso es una definición de la cultura humana.
Lo que descubrimos es que durante estos 40 y tantos años
en los que yo y otros hemos estado estudiando chimpancés
y otros grandes simios, y, como digo, otros mamíferos
con cerebros complejos y sistemas sociales complejos,
descubrimos que después de todo, no hay una línea definida
que divida a los humanos del resto del reino animal.
Es una línea muy confusa.
Que se vuelve más confusa cada vez que descubrimos animales haciendo cosas
que nosotros, en nuestra arrogancia, pensábamos que eran solamente humanas.
Los chimpancés -- no hay tiempo para discutir sus fascinantes vidas --
tienen una infancia larga, cinco años
de amamantarse y dormirse con su madre,
y luego otros tres, cuatro o cinco años
dependiendo emocionalmente de ella, aún cuando haya nacido el siguiente hijo.
La importancia de aprender durante ese tiempo, cuando el comportamiento es flexible --
y hay muchísimo que aprender en la sociedad chimpancé.
Los lazos afectivos a largo plazo
que se desarrollan durante esta larga infancia con la madre,
con los hermanos y hermanas,
y que pueden durar toda la vida,
que podría ser hasta los 60 años.
De hecho, pueden vivir más de 60 años en cautiverio,
así que sólo los hemos estudiado durante 40 años en la vida silvestre, hasta ahora.
Y descubrimos que los chimpancés son capaces de auténtica compasión y altruismo.
Descubrimos en su comunicación no-verbal, que es muy rica,
que tienen muchos sonidos que usan en distintas situaciones,
pero también usan el tacto, la postura y los gestos,
y ¿qué hacen?
Se besan, se abrazan, se toman de las manos.
Se dan palmaditas en la espalda, se pavonean, agitan su puño --
el tipo de cosas que hacemos nosotros --
y lo hacen en el mismo contexto.
Cooperan de una forma muy sofisticada.
A veces cazan -- no muy seguido,
pero cuando cazan cooperan de manera sofisticada,
y comparten la presa.
Encontramos que muestran emociones, similares -- a veces tal vez las mismas --
que las que describimos en nosotros como felicidad, tristeza, miedo, desolación.
Pueden sufrir tanto física como mentalmente.
Y no tengo tiempo para extenderme con la información
que les probaría algunas de estas cosas,
salvo decir que hay estudiantes brillantes en las mejores universidades
que están estudiando emociones en los animales, estudiando personalidades en los animales.
Sabemos que los chimpancés y algunas otras criaturas
pueden reconocerse en los espejos -- diferenciarse de otros.
Tienen sentido del humor, y este tipo de cosas
que tradicionalmente se ha pensado que eran prerrogativas humanas.
Pero esto nos enseña un nuevo respeto -- un nuevo respeto
no sólo para los chimpancés, diría,
sino para algunos de los otros animales increíbles con quienes compartimos este planeta.
Una vez que estemos preparados para admitir que después de todo,
no somos los únicos seres con personalidades, mentes
y sobre todo sentimientos, y cuando empezamos a pensar
en las formas en que usamos y abusamos
de tantas otras criaturas sensibles y sapientes en este planeta,
nos da un motivo para sentir una profunda vergüenza, al menos para mí.
Entonces, lo triste es que estos chimpancés --
que quizás nos han enseñado, más que cualquier otra criatura, un poco de humildad --
están en el bosque, desapareciendo rápidamente.
Están desapareciendo por las razones
que todos ustedes en este cuarto conocen demasiado bien.
La deforestación, el crecimiento de las poblaciones humanas que necesitan más tierra.
Están desapareciendo porque algunas compañías madereras
avanzan abriendo claros.
Están desapareciendo del corazón de África
porque las grandes compañías madereras multinacionales han venido y han hecho caminos --
como quieren hacer en Ecuador
y otras partes donde los bosques permanecen intactos --
para extraer petróleo o madera.
Y esto ha llevado en la cuenca del Congo, y en otras partes del mundo,
a lo que se conoce como comercio de carne de monte.
Esto significa que aunque durante cientos, tal vez miles de años,
ha vivido gente en esas selvas, o el hábitat que sea,
en harmonía con su mundo, sólo matando a los animales que necesitan
para el consumo familiar --
ahora, repentinamente, gracias a los caminos,
los cazadores pueden entrar desde los pueblos.
Le disparan a todo, a todas y cada una de las cosas que se muevan
que sean más grandes que una rata pequeña, lo secan al sol o lo ahúman.
Y ahora tienen transporte, lo llevan en los camiones madereros
o en los camiones mineros hacia los pueblos donde los venden.
Y la gente paga más por esta "carne-de-monte", como le dicen,
que por la carne doméstica -- la prefieren culturalmente.
Y esto no es sustentable, y los gigantescos campamentos madereros en la selva
ahora demandan carne, para corrompiendo a los cazadores Pigmeos
de la cuenca del Congo que han vivido ahí con su maravillosa forma de vida
por tantos cientos de años.
Les han dado armas, disparan en nombre de los campamentos, reciben dinero.
Su cultura está siendo destruida,
junto con los animales de los que dependen.
Entonces, cuando se van los campamentos madereros, no queda nada.
Ya hemos hablado sobre la pérdida de diversidad cultural humana,
y lo he visto ocurrir con mis propios ojos.
Y la triste imágen en África -- Amo a África,
¿y qué vemos en África?
Vemos deforestación,
vemos que el desierto se expande, vemos hambrunas masivas,
vemos enfermedades y crecimiento poblacional en áreas
donde hay más personas viviendo en un pedazo de tierra
que las que esa tierra puede soportar,
y son muy pobres para comprar comida de algún otro lado.
¿Las personas sobre las que escuchamos ayer,
en la Isla de Pascua, que talaron su último árbol -- eran tontos?
¿No sabían lo que estaba ocurriendo?
Por supuesto, pero si vieran la abrumadora pobreza
que hay en algunas partes del mundo
no es una cuestión de -- dejemos este árbol para mañana.
Sino de "¿Cómo alimentaré a mi familia hoy?
Tal vez pueda obtener unos pocos dólares por este último árbol
y con eso podremos seguir un poco más,
y después rezaremos para que algo suceda
que nos salve del inevitable final".
Esta es una imagen bastante desalentadora
Lo único que tenemos, que nos hace tan diferentes
de los chimpancés o de otras criaturas,
es este sofisticado lenguaje --
un lenguaje con el que podemos decirle a los niños
sobre cosas que no están ahí.
Podemos hablar sobre el pasado distante, planear hacia el futuro distante,
discutir ideas unos con otros,
para que las ideas crezcan mediante la sabiduría acumulada de un grupo.
Podemos hacerlo hablando entre nosotros,
podemos hacerlo mediante el video, podemos hacerlo mediante la palabra escrita.
Y estamos abusando de este grandioso poder que tenemos para ser sabios administradores,
y estamos destruyendo el mundo.
En el mundo desarrollado, de cierta forma, es peor,
porque podemos fácilmente saber
la estupidez de lo que estamos haciendo.
Saben, estamos trayendo bebés
a un mundo donde, en muchos lugares, el agua los está matando.
Y el aire los daña, y la comida que se cultiva
en las tierras contaminadas los envenena.
Y eso no sólo en el lejano mundo subdesarrollado, eso ocurre en todas partes.
¿Sabían que todos tenemos como 50 químicos
en nuestros cuerpos que no estaban hace unos 50 años?
Y muchas de estas enfermedades, como el asma
y algunos tipos de cáncer, se han incrementado
en lugares donde nuestros asquerosos desechos tóxicos se tiran.
Nos estamos dañando a nosotros mismos en todo el mundo,
así como estamos dañando a los animales y a la naturaleza misma.
La Madre Naturaleza, que nos hizo ser.
La Madre Naturaleza, donde creo que debemos pasar más tiempo,
donde hay árboles, flores y aves
para nuestro buen desarrollo psicológico.
Y aún así, hay cientos y cientos de niños
en el mundo desarrollado, quienes nunca han visto la naturaleza,
porque han crecido en el cemento
y todo lo que conocen es la realidad virtual,
sin oportunidades de ir y echarse al sol,
o en el bosque, con las moteadas pintas de sol
que bajan de los altos doseles.
Mientras viajaba por el mundo, saben,
tuve que dejar la selva -- que es donde me encanta estar.
Tuve que dejar a esos fascinantes chimpancés
para que mis estudiantes y el equipo continuaran estudiando
porque, al descubrir que se habían reducido de unos dos millones
hace 100 años hasta unos 150,000 ahora,
supe que tenía que abandonar la selva para hacer lo que pudiera
para despertar la conciencia en todo el mundo.
Y mientras más platicaba sobre la grave situación de los chimpancés,
más me daba cuenta del hecho de que todo está interconectado,
y que los problemas del mundo en vías de desarrollo
frecuentemente se derivan de la avaricia del mundo desarrollado,
y que todo se estaba uniendo y siendo -- sinsentido,
en "sentido" está la esperanza, dicen -- está siendo un sinsentido.
¿Cómo lo podemos hacer?
Alguien dijo eso ayer,
y mientras viajaba porel mundo, me reuní con jóvenes que habían perdido la esperanza.
se sentían desesperados,
ellos decían "bueno, no importa lo que hagamos,
comer, beber y ser alegres, ya que mañana moriremos.
ya no hay esperanza -- es lo que siempre nos dicen los medios."
Y luego conocí a algunos que estaban enojados,
y el enojo puede convertirse en violencia,
y todos estamos familiarizados con eso.
Tengo tres nietecitos,
y cuando alguno de estos estudiantes me dice
en el bachillerato o en la universidad, me dicen, "Estamos enojados,"
o "Hemos perdido la esperanza, porque sentimos
que ustedes han comprometido nuestro futuro, y no hay nada que podamos hacer al respecto."
Y vi los ojos de mis nietecitos,
y pienso en lo mucho que hemos dañado este planeta desde que yo tenía su edad.
Siento esta profunda vergüenza, y por eso en 1991 en Tanzania,
empecé un programa llamado Roots and Shoots [Raíces y Brotes].
Hay folletos afuera por todas partes,
y si cualquiera de ustedes tiene algo que ver con los niños y les importa su futuro,
les ruego que tomen uno.
Roots and Shoots es un programa para la esperanza.
Roots [Raíces] crea una base firme.
Shoots [los Brotes] se ven pequeños,
pero para alcanzar el sol pueden romper paredes de ladrillo.
Vean la pared como los problemas
que hemos provocado en este planeta.
Entonces, ven, este es un mensaje de esperanza.
Cientos y miles de jóvenes en todo el mundo
pueden atravesarlas, y pueden hacer de éste un mundo mejor.
Y el mensaje más importante de Roots and Shoots
es que cada individuo hace la diferencia.
Cada individuo tiene una tarea que realizar.
Cada uno de nosotros impactamos el mundo a nuestro alrededor cada día,
y ustedes científicos, saben que de hecho no pueden --
aún si se quedan todo el día en cama, están respirando oxígeno
y liberando CO2, y probablemente van al baño,
y cosas como esas.
Están haciendo una diferencia en el mundo.
Entonces, el programa Roots and Shoots
involucra a la juventud en tres tipos de proyectos.
Y éstos son proyectos que hacen el mundo a su alrededor un mejor lugar.
Un proyecto para enseñar a cuidar y preocuparse por su propia comunidad humana.
Uno para animales, incluyendo animales domésticos -- y debo decir,
aprendí todo lo que sé sobre comportamiento animal
aún antes de ir a Gombe y los chimpancés, de mi perro, Rusty,
que fue mi compañero de la infancia.
Y el tercer tipo de proyecto, algo por el medio ambiente local.
Lo que hacen los niños depende, primero, de su edad.
Y ahora vamos desde pre-escolar hasta la universidad.
dependerá si están en un área urbana o rural.
Dependerá si tienen recursos o son pobres.
Dependerá de qué parte, digamos, de EEUU estén.
Ahora estamos en todos los estados, y los problemas en Florida
son diferentes a los problemas en Nueva York
Dependerá de en qué país estén --
y ya estamos en más de 60 países, con unos 5,000 grupos activos --
y oigo de grupos en todos lados sobre los que nunca
había escuchado antes, porque los niños están tomando el programa
y esparciéndolo ellos mismos.
¿Por qué?
Porque creen en el programa,
y son quienes deciden lo que harán.
No es algo que les dicen sus padres,
o sus maestros.
Eso es efectivo, pero si deciden por sí mismos,
"Queremos limpiar este río
y hacer que vuelvan los peces.
Queremos limpiar los tóxicos del suelo
de esta zona y tener un jardín orgánico.
Queremos pasar tiempo con las personas mayores
y escuchar y grabar sus historias.
Queremos trabajar en un refugio canino.
Queremos aprender sobre los animales. queremos..."
Saben, esto sigue y sigue, y esto me da esperanza.
Cuando viajo alrededor del mundo 300 días al año,
en todas partes hay un grupo de diferentes edades de Roots and Shoots.
En todas partes hay niños con ojos brillantes diciendo,
"Mira la diferencia que hemos hecho."
Y ahora entra en juego la nueva tecnología,
porque con esta nueva forma de comunicarse electrónicamente
estos chicos pueden comunicarse entre sí alrededor del mundo.
Y si a alguien le interesa ayudarnos, tenemos muchas ideas
pero necesitamos ayuda -- necesitamos ayuda para crear el tipo de sistema adecuado
que ayudará a estos jóvenes a comunicar su emoción.
Pero también, y esto es importante, a comunicar su desesperación,
para decir, "Hemos intentado esto y no funciona, ¿qué debemos hacer?"
Y luego, quién lo diría, está este otro grupo respondiéndole a estos niños
que podrían estar en EEUU, o tal vez sea un grupo en Israel,
diciendo "Sí, se equivocaron un poco. Así es como debe hacerse."
La filosofía es muy sencilla:
No creemos en la violencia.
No violencia, no bombas, no armas.
Esa no es la forma de arreglar los problemas.
La violencia conduce a la violencia, al menos desde mi punto de vista.
Entonces ¿cómo lo resolvemos?
Las herramientas para resolver los problemas son el conocimiento y la comprensión.
Conocer los hechos, pero ver cómo es que caben en la situación general.
Trabajo duro y persistencia -- no rendirse--
el amor y la compasión crean respeto hacia toda la vida.
¿Cuántos minutos más? ¿Dos, uno?
Chris Anderson: Uno -- uno o dos.
Jane goodall: Dos, dos, me tardaré dos.
(Risas)
¿Vendrán a sacarme a rastras?
Bueno -- entonces, Roots and Shoots
está empezando a cambiar la vida de los jóvenes.
Es a lo que estoy dedicándole la mayor parte de mi energía.
Y creo que un grupo como éste puede tener un impacto muy grande,
no sólo porque pueden compartir la tecnología con nosotros,
sino porque muchos de ustedes tienen niños.
Y si toman este programa, y se lo dan a sus niños,
tendrán una muy buena oportunidad para salir y hacer el bien,
porque tienen padres como ustedes.
Y está claro cuánto les importa
intentar hacer de este mundo un mejor lugar.
Es muy motivante.
Pero los niños me preguntan --
y esto no tomará más de dos minutos, lo prometo --
los niños dicen, "Dra. Jane, de verdad tiene esperanzas en el futuro?
Usted viaja, ve que ocurren estas cosas horribles."
Primero, el cerebro humano -- no necesito decir nada al respecto,
Ahora que sabemos qué problemas hay en el mundo,
mentes como las suyas están surgiendo para resorlver estos problemas.
Y hemos hablado bastante al respecto.
Segundo, la resiliencia de la naturaleza.
Podemos destruir un río,
y podemos volverlo a la vida.
Podemos ver un área completa desolada,
y podemos hacer que florezca nuevamente, con tiempo o un poco de ayuda.
Y tercero, el último orador habló sobre -- o el penúltimo,
habló sobre el indomable espíritu humano.
Estamos rodeados por las personas más maravillosas
que hacen cosas que parecieran ser absolutamente imposibles.
Nelson mandela -- Tomé esta pieza de cal
de la prisión Robben Island, donde trabajó por 27 años,
y salió con tanta amargura, que pudo sacar a su gente
del horror del apartheid sin un baño de sangre.
Aún después del 11 de Septiembre -- y yo estaba en Nueva york
y sentí el miedo -- sin embargo, había tanto valor humano,
tanto amor y tanta compasión.
Y entonces mientras recorría el país después de eso y luego de sentir el temor --
el temor que estaba haciendo que la gente sintiera
que no podrían preocuparse más sobre el ambiente
para que no pareciera que no eran patriotas --
y yo intentaba motivarlos,
alguien vino con una cita de Mahatma Gandhi,
"Si ves en retrospectiva la historia de la humanidad,
verás que todos los regímenes malvados han sido superados por el bien."
Y justo después de eso una mujer me dio esta campanita,
y quiero terminar con esta nota.
Dijo, "Si hablas sobre esperanza y paz, haz sonar esto.
Esta campana está hecha con metal de una mina desactivada,
de los campos de muerte de Pol Pot --
uno de los regímenes más malvados de la historia --
donde las personas ahora comienzan a recuperar sus vidas
después de que este régimen ha caído".
Entonces, sí, hay esperanza, y ¿dónde está?
¿Está ahí donde los políticos?
Está en nuestras manos.
En sus manos y en las mías
y en las de nuestros niños.
Realmente depende de nosotros.
Somos nosotros quienes podemos hacer la diferencia.
Si tenemos vidas en las que conscientemente
dejamos la huella ecológica más ligera posible,
si compramos las cosas que son éticas para nosotros
y no compramos lo que no lo es,
podemos cambiar el mundo de la noche a la mañana.
Gracias.